so there is something there that we call
the ego now is it your subjectivity in
and of itself or not that's a valid
question I would answer that it the ego
is not your subjectivity it it's it's a
certain configuration of experiences or
a narrative within your subjectivity and
yes idealism ultimately is a form of
cosmic solipsism and you can dip your
toes in those Waters and you recoil from
it I call it the vertigo of Eternity
it's a place that is very hard to visit
very hard to confront um which may be a
clue to why we are here you know in this
form but maturing has always to do with
poking you out of your comfort zone and
and and and buffeting you a little